someone like you does not end up here by
choice which is your crime when I was in
Moscow I heard about a program young
officers trained to seduce and
manipulate to get information
Terri's color sparrows
[Music]
make these men pay I'll find a way
red Sparrow honey mama what is it I have
to go with Roy
I was told to take a man to hotel I said
that he was an enemy of the state take
off your dress
and in exchange my mother could get the
doctor she need him instead they cut his
throat
there could be no witnesses so they gave
me a choice die or become a sparrow from
this day forward you will become
space-weapons in a global struggle for
power you'll be trained in a
psychological manipulation you must
learn to push yourself beyond all
limitation take off your clothes when we
are finished with you the person you
were will no longer exist every human
being is a puzzle of need you must
become the missing piece and they will
tell you anything you have a gift you
know how to survive this is what you
were meant to talk
visit rater and the government
his last known contact is an American
lipgloss I'm a Pharisee in the pool
yesterday are we going to become friends
is Ellen you want
it's a sparrow the only man cause of
what you can do for them work with me
and make these men pay you are better
this than any of us your only problem is
you have a soul
we can't trust a word that comes out of
her mouth
there's something else we're not seeing
if she's compromised she will be
eliminated what have you done
you belong to them they won't ever let
go I'll find a way
you